there is plenty of advice for how to
improve your sleep
go to bed at the same time avoid digital
screens
after dark and don't hit snooze
but it all comes down to the same
assumption that you're doing something
wrong
when in fact it may not be your fault at
all
inside practically every organism on
earth
there's a clock that keeps order known
as the circadian rhythm
for humans it's located in the part of
our brain called the hypothalamus
and while it's most famous for
controlling our sleep cycles
it's also responsible for helping
primary organs like the brain
heart and lungs work in harmony
but not everyone's circadian rhythm is
the same
night owls for instance generally feel
tired later than early birds
often because they produce high amounts
of the sleep hormone melatonin
later at night and for most of human
history that didn't matter
since night owls could protect their
tribes from nocturnal predators or their
cities from cunning conquerors
but society has made it a problem in
recent decades
an estimated 80 percent of americans
follow daily schedules that fall between
6 a.m and 6 p.m yet
nearly a third of the population
considers themselves
night owls which means they're better
off with a schedule that looks more like
this this phenomenon is called social
jet lag
it's like the jet lag you feel after a
long plane trip
but worse because it doesn't disappear
after a few days
and social jet lag is taking its toll on
the night owls of the world
because even if you get the recommended
amount of sleep
knocking your circadian rhythm out of
whack has consequences
for example one study found that for
every hour your circadian rhythm is out
of sync
your risk of obesity increases by 33
also increasing your risk of the many
health complications associated with
obesity
and the problem isn't just a physical
one in another study
people whose circadian rhythms were more
than two
hours off reported notably more severe
symptoms of depression
and since your circadian rhythm tends to
shift as you age
social jet lag is especially apparent in
teens
in fact the cdc warns that most public
schools across
america start too early before 8 30
which according to the non-profit rand
corporation
is costing the country nine billion
dollars a year
from mainly lost academic performance
and car crashes from tired teens behind
the wheel
luckily the circadian rhythm isn't set
in stone
turns out it's largely triggered by
light signals that strike your eye
so when you first wake up get outside
and soak up some morning
sun or if that's out of the question
make sure your home is well lit
it might just brighten your morning a
little more
we'd like to learn what you want to know
about the human body
tell us in the comments and thanks for
watching